The first stage in the process is the illuminant;
that is, what creates the light that falls
on the scene that is ultimately reflected
into our eyes. So where does the light come
from? Well there are many, many different
sources of light; incandescence’s is emitted
by hot objects, that could be the white hot
filament of a tungsten light bulb or it could be the sun.
Old fashion cathode ray tubes—as found in
televisions and old computer monitors—generate
light by firing very energetic electrons at
phosphors and these are chemicals that accept
that high energy electron and convert that
into photons or light.
We also have light emitting diodes, gas discharge
tubes and lasers.
Way back in 1672, Isaac Newton developed what
he called the spectral theory of light and
he did a very famous experiment, light entered
the room through a hole in a covering over
the window and entered a prism where he saw
that it was split into many different colors.
And then he was able to show that he could
recombine the multiple colors of light back
into a single beam of white light.
What you see here is an image of Isaac Newton’s
notebook that records this experiment that
he did.
A very iconic image is of a beam of white
light entering a prism and being split into
all of the colors of the rainbow. These different
colors represent light of different frequencies
and we tend to describe the frequency of a
particular color of light in terms of its
wavelength. It is a length and it is measured
in units of nanometers; ten to the minus nine
meters. Now, not all light is visible, human
beings are able to see light between about
400 nanometers and 700 nanometers. Light with
wavelengths shorter than 400 nanometers we
refer to as ultra-violet and light with wavelengths
greater than 700 nanometers we refer to as
infra-red.
Light is an electromagnetic wave and if we
look at this graphically we see that there
are two
self-reinforcing waves, moving through space
in this direction along the x axis. One of
those waves is an electric field; the other
wave is a magnetic field. The length of a
single cycle of either of these waves we refer
to as the wavelength and very commonly give
it the symbol lambda.
So the wavelength is the length of a single
cycle of this electromagnetic wave and for
light it is between 400 and 700 nanometers.
Let’s now consider black body radiators
and the two most common black body sources
of light that we use are the traditional incandescent
tungsten light bulb, though these are now
going out of fashion, and the sun. The sun
is a very hot object in the sky that omits
visible light.
The amount of light that a black body radiator
omits as a function of its wavelength is given
by this curve here. The visible range of light
is shown here. This curve is described by
Planck’s law and it contains a large number
of constance, and one of the terms in this
expression is T, that is the temperature of
the black body radiator. That is the temperature
of the tungsten filament or it is the temperature
of the surface of the sun.
Typically, these are in the order of thousands
of degrees kelvin. The curve has got a very
clear peak, and the wavelength of this peak
is given by the Wien displacement law, and
what this shows is that the wavelength associated
with the maximum of this peak is inversely
related to the temperature.
So low temperatures have a large lambda associated
with the peak and as the temperature increases
this lambda acts, decreases. It moves to a
shorter wavelength. And we actually have an
intuitive feel for this: what I have plotted
here are the black body emission curves for
black bodies at a range of different temperatures — from 1000 kelvin up to 6000 kelvin — and as we
can see, as the temperature increases, the
wavelength associated with the maximum is
moving towards a smaller wavelength … it
is becoming more blue. So as its temperature
increases, the wavelength associated with
the maximum emission moves to lower wavelengths,
to bluer colors.
In our language we use colors to describe
temperatures. Something that is pretty hot,
metal that is just about to begin be able
to be worked, we describe as being red hot.
As we increase the temperature it becomes
yellow hot, it is glowing a different color,
it is more yellow now and as the temperature
goes up it starts to omit white light. And
we refer to that as being white hot.
Let’s have a go at plotting one of these
black body curves. To get started with, just
to make life a little bit easier for myself
I am going to define a symbol NM, stands for
nanometer and is equal to one by ten to the
minus nine. Make life a little bit easier.
And I am going to create a vector of wavelengths.
I am going to call it lambda and it is going
to vary from three hundred nanometers in steps
of ten nanometers all the way up to a thousand
nanometers, this is going from the near ultra-violet
through into the infra-red part of the spectrum.
Now I can compute a black body radiator emission
curve, using the black body function. I parse
in the range of wavelengths that I am interested
in and I parse in the temperature. And I am
going to put in 6500 kelvin, which is the
temperature of the sun. I can plot this curve,
one axis is going to be lambda and the other
axis is going to be E. And here we have a
plot of the response of the black body radiator.
I am going to put a grid on there.
Let’s look at the case now for a black body
radiator, but at a lower color temperature
and I am going to reduce the color temperature
a little bit.
So let’s come back here and I am going to
reduce the color by 500 degrees. Put that
into the variable E. I am going to overlay
that plot and now I am going to plot E against
lambda and I am going to do it with dashline
so we can see what’s the difference. And
what we can see is that the curve is lower;
this slightly cooler body is emitting less
energy overall. The peak of its omission has
moved from around 450 nanometers to closer
to 480 nanometers. So it has got a little bit cooler and it is a little bit more red in its appearance.